definitivamente la fila se abrió y hemos
visto que cada vez va más avanzando más
y más pero ha advertido el gobierno que
ahora el tiempo de espera para poder
entrar a la cámara ardiente de isabel
segura ha alcanzado las 24 horas y
podría seguir aumentando durante el fin
de semana podemos ver que se dupliquen e
incluso que se tripliquen por la
cantidad de personas que son esperadas
quienes están en la fila a esta hora que
ustedes pueden ver a mis espaldas han
estado haciendo fila por 10 horas y
lejos de querer dejarla por el frío las
bajas temperaturas a esta hora han dicho
que por el contrario es un estímulo más
para poder despedirse personalmente de
la reina isabel segunda pese a que la
cámara ardiente de westminster hall
alcanzan a estar máximo un par de
minutos causó sensación en las redes
sociales y también en la fila que en la
estrella del fútbol inglés david beckham
hizo fila 12 horas para poder despedirse
personalmente de la reina y ha dicho que
lo hizo porque quería
tributo a isabel segunda quien conoció
personalmente por su trabajo como lo
menciona es el rey carlos ha tenido una
agenda bien agitada hoy en las próximas
horas liderará aquí en la abadía aquí en
el westminster hall una vigilia con sus
hermanos y además se ha confirmado que
la primera ministra liz tras quien
apenas lleva una semana en el cargo
tendrá reuniones con líderes del mundo
durante el funeral de isabel segunda ese
será el fin de semana una de ellas con
el presidente de eeuu joe biden